the exhibition is called Cambodia the
venn my workshop in the conference is on
creation and post memory and both the
exhibition and conference are part of a
citywide festival in New York called
season of Cambodia the whole idea came
out of a series of workshop that we
created in Cambodia engaging but not one
of the seven survivor of s21 the tour
slang prison and young emerging visual
artists who really kind of connect and
create that expressions of the atrocity
that had happened to Cambodia but in
their own way post memory concerns
effects and troubles linked to crisis
mass murders as a preceding generation
for me was in relation to the Holocaust
first and but then it became a notion
that other people found resonant for
other kinds of historical events and
other other historical catastrophes so
the conference and the exhibition
concern is centered on the Cambodian
genocide but it brings together a kind
of comparative analysis of a number of
different genocides and I want to say
right away that I don't think those
situations can be compared but there are
some structures of remembrance that in
our global world travel through and
bridge some of those distances very well
you want to give a future for our
country we need to go back to Cambodia
and try to to do something on memory for
the young generation so I was there when
the Khmer Rouge arrived and so Oh
still inside me so I have to work on it
I have the experience of five years war
when I was 13 young soldier Marusia put
his ak-47 in my head so all these
feelings are still alive inside me so I
talk about this the real difference
between the Holocaust which is the area
that I've studied and the Cambodian
genocide has precisely to do with visual
imagery the Holocaust was probably the
most photographed event of the 20th
century that's not the case for Cambodia
I mean what survived are those the
photographs of the prisoners in the s21
torture center that were taken by
perpetrators and the victims themselves
had to produce an image archive that
wasn't available but not who was the
painter really came in terms of more
like sharing his what he have lived
through to this new generation who
didn't went through at all I'm a young
generation who born after the Khmer
Rouge I didn't know about it and
something that I learned from my parents
and I learnt from school like it's not
enough but when I attend the the the
workshop I feel like wow it's not it's
not something that is normal but is
something that how can you move on
without knowing your history without
knowing what has happened to your
country the first it's look all the
archives not just on Khmer Rouge regime
but what what they want about our
culture our
while history the remarkable thing about
this exhibition is that this is the
archive that's now come to New York and
it's art that was produced precisely to
compensate for the absence of visual
imagery or an artistic expression are a
way of reviving a connection to a past
which was in which there was an attempt
to deliberately sever the relationship
to that past and carry it on so I think
it's both redemptive and also expressive
of the collective tragedy it's art
created through memory but also through
post memories through inherited stories
and accounts that have shaped the
imagination of the generations that
followed that didn't live through the
event didn't even hear about it until
years later but that nevertheless has
created this remarkable body of work